el super bowl es el gran evento
deportivo del año en estados unidos la
final del fútbol americano es un día
importantísimo en la cultura y todo lo
que rodea este deporte se vuelve un
espectáculo televisivo mundial que mueve
millones de millones de dólares y para
esta edición los anuncios de 30 segundos
tienen un costo que va desde los 6.2
millones de dólares hasta los 7 millones
por otro lado los jugadores del equipo
vencedor se llevarán 130 mil dólares
esto cada uno las entradas más baratas
para asistir al juego tienen un precio
superior a los 4 mil 200 dólares y la
ubicación no es la mejor para éste
halftime el show está confirmada la
presencia de cinco artistas hablamos de
snoop dogg doctortrade merisi play
eminem y kendrick la marca todos ellos
raperos de la causa oeste de eeuu y para
entender este megaevento la importancia
y por supuesto todo el dinero que mueve
quiere salvar en este momento aquiles
este él es consultor de marca y director
crea profesor de gestión de contenido de
marca en la universidad de miami y
colaborador de opinión del 'new york
times' gracias aquiles por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
hablemos primero de la publicidad y
todas las estrategias de marketing qué
tan importante es para las marcas tener
un espacio en el super bowl es muy
importante ya es una tradición americana
estar allí particularmente para las
empresas de consumo masivo el superbowl
a anunciar allí ha quedado para empresas
como frito-lay como microsoft
como la automotriz es decir empresas que
tienen que comercializar masivamente sus
productos de sus servicios
hay una gran novedad
una empresa de script o monedas que
comercializa secreto moneda cripto camps
que estará presente es una gran novedad
no se había visto esa categoría
anteriormente que indica bueno la
fortaleza que está adquiriendo este
sector económico financiero no solamente
los estaba unido sino el mundo esa es la
gran novedad en esta oportunidad
aquí les hablamos ahora entonces de todo
el dinero que se mueve alrededor del
superbowl cuáles son las expectativas de
ganancia cuánto se planea recaudar este
año lo mejor frente al año anterior
bueno es un número muy especulativo en
verdad
todos
anticipan números antes del super bowl
pero la realidad real es que sus números
tienden a ser muy dudosos las marcas se
esfuerzan las grandes compañías es decir
que gastan qué sé yo 7 millones de
dólares por un anuncio de 30 segundos
pero esas cifras en mi modesta
experiencia tienden a ser muy dudosas
son parte de operaciones de relaciones
públicas en ese sentido muy difíciles y
una cifra real que revele lo que
realmente se gasta en el futuro son
cifras millonarias que en verdad la al
día se mantienen muy en secreto porque
son negociaciones muy delicadas que se
mantienen con el canal de televisión que
airea el evento y con la propia nfl la
liga del fútbol americano la realidad
pura es que vale la pena invertir allí a
pesar de las costosísimas cifras porque
es el evento indiscutiblemente el evento
de televisión indiscutiblemente más
visto en los eeuu y visto hoy en día en
todo a pesar de que la gente no entiende
las
sofisticadas reglas del fútbol americano
pero lo ven para ver los comerciales y
el evento el concierto de 'el
intermedio' el show de medio tiempo y
hace quería llegar a aquiles porque es
un punto muy importante de este super
bowl a lo largo de la historia ha
ocurrido grandes espectáculos ya sea por
la calidad de los autistas de los
artistas el desempeño que ellos ponen en
el escenario para hacer este gran show
le pregunto cuál es la importancia de
este evento para ellos y la repercusión
entonces en las ventas monetariamente
también de sus discos de su publicidad
qué beneficios le traen a ellos además
le quiero preguntar algo ellos pagan por
presentarse en el superbowl es
totalmente gratuito digamos no no son
ellos porque ellos ellos reciben una
paga enorme por estar allí no es
cualquiera el que llega al
al eventos de medio tiempo del super
love son artistas consagrados son
artistas que tienen ya una base enorme
de seguidores no solamente los estados
unidos sino en todo el mundo
yo recuerdo muy especialmente si me
preguntan cuál es el que más me ha
impactado recuerdo por ejemplo el de
prince en el año 2016 eso impactó a todo
el mundo había anuncios de lluvia lo
llamaron para preguntarme si iba a tocar
el dios que sí que más aún con lluvia y
toco por kurt reintsch bajo la lluvia
eso fue absolutamente apoteósico así ha
habido muchos otros pero el estar en el
super bowl como un artista pop es algo
que consagra tu carrera
la relanza muchas veces son artistas que
ya vienen con grandes trayectorias y que
relanza su carrera en fin pasa de todo
en esta oportunidad como tú has dicho
hay muchos raperos son un número
importante de artistas 5 eso es inusual
por cierto normalmente nos bastan de dos
o tres esta vez hay cinco o seis
en el rap de un género que está
rescatando el superbowl tiene que ver
por cierto con el apoyo la necesidad que
tienen muchos anunciantes muchos canales
de televisión muchos medios de apoyar a
las minorías que por cierto es un apoyo
que reciben las minorías en los medios
en medio de una grave crisis que hay en
este país eeuu
respecto a los crímenes
a minorías es muy paradójico el momento
en ese sentido eso le quería también
decir se trata también esta invitación
algo a propósito de tocar el tema racial
en estados unidos que también ha
afectado el deporte el fútbol americano
el super bowl era el tema racial va a
estar va a estar en el medio tiempo y el
tema racial va a estar en prácticamente
yo diría la mayoría de los anuncios que
ya muchos de ellos ya los hemos visto
porque eso es otra gran novedad en el
superbowl antes la gente esperaba el
propio reto para ver los famosos
anuncios publicitarios pero con internet
ya nada se puede esperar por el momento
si preciso los anuncios casi todos ya
están en youtube ya casi todos se pueden
ver libremente y bueno siendo tu
pregunta en muchos de estos muchos de
estos anuncios tiene artistas tienen las
figuras tienen a celebrities
afro-americanos del chino de minorías
raciales aquí en los eeuu que nuevamente
van a aparecer allí pero en medio de
estas políticas polémicas esta gran
discusión nacional sobre el aumento de
crímenes y atentados a miembros de
minorías étnicas o racial
aquiles también como lo venimos diciendo
este es un gran evento que millones de
personas lo siguen por la televisión no
sólo en eeuu y that sino también
alrededor del mundo podemos hacer un
estimado de cuántas personas espera que
vean el superbowl este domingo bueno hay
también las cifras son muy especulativas
y en los eeuu esto puede llegar
fácilmente a 80 millones de espectadores
en el mundo realmente no tendría una
cifra
precisa responsable que dar eso varía
muchísimo lo que sí podemos asegurar es
que eso va creciendo años normalmente
porque los anuncios la presencia de
celebridades el concierto del medio
tiempo son absolutamente eventos
globales y también habría que decir aquí
en los estados unidos hay una discusión
ya sempiterna sobre cuál es el deporte
más americano si el béisbol o el fútbol
americano y la el hecho de que sea el
fútbol americano el evento que el evento
de televisión más visto aquí en los eeuu
pareciera confirmar que el fútbol
americano cada día gana más espacio en
este país y el béisbol es grande por
otro grande por traicionar el retador yo
va como retrocediendo en los gustos de
la población a eso le quería preguntar
entonces aquiles este deporte es el que
más dinero mueve en eeuu y sobre todo
digamos contando con la final el
superbowl
es el que más dinero mueve el que tiene
digamos yo no tengo duda en asegurar es
el que tiene más cerca el mundo de los
celebrities de hollywood de la industria
de la música pop sin duda es el deporte
que es más está moviendo dinero
últimamente el culo americano tuvo un
sesgo político importante durante los
años la presidencia de donald trump
prácticamente se asociaba a la
fanaticada del fútbol americano
a seguidores de donald trump a seguidora
del partido republicano por eso
nuevamente va ganando causas
como el grande fuerte popular de eeuu
que atraviesa todas las clases sociales
y todas las etnias en todas las minorías
raciales aquí les podemos hablar del
súper bowl más visto de la historia lo
tiene presente además si nos puede dar
algunos datos de cifras y puede darnos
la cifra de cuánto recaudo
pues mira yo recuerdo muy especialmente
el su prólogo de
1984 lo recuerdo no tanto por el juego
siempre pregunta sino por el famoso
anuncio de apple de marc dirigido por
ridley scott que todo el mundo recordará
ese anuncio se puso al aire ese día en
esa oportunidad no se podía ver
anticipadamente y yo creo que eso marcó
a una generación entera que no había
visto publicidad de ese tipo dirigida
por grandes directores de cine de
hollywood de modo que si me preguntas a
mí personalmente y creo que a mi
generación todas nos marco es el
superbowl particularmente nuevamente no
por el juego sino prueba nuncio de
macintosh
digamos el fenómeno superbowl por fuera
de eeuu como lo percibe ver aumento
huawei sin disminuir no va bang bang va
en aumento absoluto por ejemplo en
países como brasil es muy visto en
países como colombia es muy visto en
méxico es muy visto en el reino unido es
muy visto bueno porque tienen allá un
deporte primo hermano del fútbol que es
el rugby
yo puedo estar esas naciones por ahora
en argentina es muy visto de modo que va
en aumento y nuevamente tienen no tiene
que ver tanto con el deporte en sí mismo
un deporte lleno de reglas y normas muy
atlántica muy retorcida que la mayoría
en américa latina y europa no entiende
pero bueno nuevamente para eso están los
anuncios y para eso está el medio tiempo
para cautivar a esa audiencia y
mantenerla allí fija viendo el huevo si
entendieran por eso es la motivación
para ver el evento aquí les una pregunta
que dicen los medios de comunicación
especialistas en deporte en eeuu quien
es el favorito para ganar esta final de
su cuerpo el número 56 dosis de naty
bengals o los ángeles rams bueno
son equipos muy parejos están hablando
de los velos los especialistas yo no soy
un seguimento especialista en fútbol
americano migrante el porte del béisbol
pero
nada de esa hora esta noche los últimos
juegos no han sido tan
tan cerrados la última superbowl de modo
que si me preguntan yo diría por los
velos son mi opción para esta noche
bueno todo puede pasar le vamos a ver
entonces el domingo en la noche a ver
los ganadores de este súper tazón número
56 aquiles gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de francia
24 hablando de todo lo que mueve el
superbowl en términos económicos y en
términos también de publicidad de
visibilidad de este deporte que es visto
masivamente en eeuu y por supuesto
también alrededor del mundo que como
usted lo dijo cada día va más en aumento
gracias aquiles un abrazo mucho